brian cox has graced both stage and
screen for decades but is perhaps best
known for playing tv's most tyrannical
media mogul
successions logan roy
i know that you've read a lot of books
about
business management and this and that
but
you know what
what
sometimes it is a big dick competition
the media dynasty at the center of this
hbo hit drama has drawn numerous
real-life comparisons from the murdochs
and the maxwells
to the redstones and the trumps
in the economist asks podcast cox
reveals his own understanding of the
flawed character he's so famous for
and why the show struck such a cord in
america's current climate of cultural
division
and political polarization
brian cox welcome to the economist asks
thank you anne thank you nice to see you
again after all these years
yes we should perhaps let our audience
in in on that little secret i came on a
tour with the national theater four just
after the fall of the berlin wall in
eastern europe and you were playing
king lear and some might say in
succession you kind of still are there's
elements i mean it's uh you have to
accept that
there's something kind of universal and
archetypal about
the characters and particularly logan
he's a he's a kind of archetype and uh
leah of course is an archetype so they
they
they do cross over considerably you're
publishing a memoir putting the rabbit
in the hat and there you write you love
playing logan roy but what sets him
apart from other stage and screen
villains you've played in in the past
whether it's hannibal lecter and
manhunter helen curry in nuremberg
obviously some people look at you and
think we can cast him as the big bad guy
it's always a privilege to to get the
role
um i i think that
the the real concern of the real job
is to understand the humanity of people
to understand where they come from you
know
you know if you look at a baby or you
look at an infant they
they don't come into the world bad
they develop it or they develop good
those things are conditions and
conditioning counts for everything
and logan i think there's a tragic
element to logan because he's
he clearly has had some kind of trauma
in his life we don't quite know what it
is
and we all may never know what it is and
the result is who he's become now but
from the actor's point of view you have
to really
understand the life and the conditions
that have made you and the decisions
that you've come to
to stop talking to be monosyllabic
because he's quite monosyllabic and he
is
he is a he's a misanthrope you know he
and i
you know we have
a lot of things in common and the fact
that we are both both deeply
disappointed with the human experiment
especially at the moment it doesn't look
very good
uh with the
crises we have around us and so somebody
like logan is a man who is ruthless
seemingly uncaring
but he actually the one thing that's
in a way anyway his is
is
is his achilles heel but also
something that
that kind of partly reclaims him is his
love for his children he does love his
children and he finds it impossible to
express that love
because in fact that love has never been
expressed to him
everybody loves speculating he it's in
inverted commas really about which
probably drives you crazy and then the
leading candidates being of course the
murdoch's family but also some of the
redstone that huge kind of venture
capitalist family even the trumps uh as
well when you're looking at a particular
scene and how you're going to address it
do you think
um i've seen this or i've read this and
i'm going to
channel it into this family in the roys
you know i mean
the roots of
the redstone family murdoch even the
horrible pink pinocchio trump you know
there are roots there you know you can
look at trump and you can see this
clearly was a child who had to survive
this awful father but then you look at
his father and think what was his
conditions you see we're all subject to
conditions
and uh murdoch's the same
and that's what's interesting
succession struck a particular
chord when it launched because it was
trumpy red zeitgeist the dysfunctional
family the sibling rivalry the
leader both uh dominant uh and also
often quite random in his judgments and
of course that focus on the role of the
media in politics do you think
succession would have felt so timely
if it weren't for the trump presidency
the irony of iron is was the fact that
we did our first episode when the day
trump was elected we had the first
read-through of the
show when trump was elected and
everybody was going off to
see hillary win
i was
i had as much as we say in scotland i
hear my dudes i hear me doots about that
you know that she was going to win
and there is an argument that she lost
as much as he wanted you know that
that's a debate too the one could have
and uh the trump presidency as anybody
and i have i lived it through it always
was appalling and it was just the
hardest time to be alive in america and
so much of the value of america he
destroyed you know
and yeah i wanted to alex and someone
said to me look this show you can read
it is a bit of a sort of liberal pinata
beating up on the wealthy and
particularly that right right wing right
leaning uh family media business do you
think that the lessons apply as much to
liberal left liberal dynasties as they
they do to conservative ones i mean
could it be also to an extent about the
abidence i think it possibly could i
think there's a
there's you know there's a sort of
willingness about the bidens which is
hard to kind of you know
but he's also part of that
whole
that whole system that american
political system and he can't escape
that um yeah i mean i think that i think
that's a fair enough point i mean and
clearly you know it i mean clearly
jesse has a kind of strong socialist
view i mean it's it's very swifty and
it's very it the whole thing has a kind
of
satirical element to it you know because
the the use of comedy the use of the the
humor in it
it gives it that sense of
you know detachment that where you can
look at it detach it and not become like
in many dramas where you're kind of
swept away but the irony is the show has
swept people away
because they're seeing people that they
love to hate and that's that's again the
human condition we as humans we love to
look at people that we love to hate and
there's no getting around that that's
just who we are
when you look around hollywood you see
so many
dynastic uh setups of
of families the extent to which
if you were already living in in around
the world of of film and of television
you have a flying start in britain we've
had uh private school systems we'd say
in america public schools we'd call it
in britain have produced really big
stars eddie redmayne betty did it come
about
to name just a couple
it does make one wonder whether the rise
of the the wealthy and and the posh has
really
had as much impact on theater television
film as it has on the restaurant
clearly has yeah i think it clearly has
you know there's no i mean somebody like
me
coming from where i came from and the
social mobility i experienced when i
came to london i mean coming from dundee
because we didn't know what was going on
and when i came to london as a young
actor uh or a young
acting student i mean i had a grant
i had living expenses i had
expenses for my scholastic expenses it
was phenomenal and i was given and we
were a lot poorer than we are now you
know and i was i was the son of a widow
and it was just extraordinary and then
to come there in the wake of the
wonderful free cinema of the of the the
late 50s early 60s with albert finney
alan bates tom courtney you know i it
was just
you know richard touching him and the
young vanessa it was an extraordinary
time
and nobody was being judged you were
always encouraged to cross the barrier
but we are so feudal in this country
that we revert back to that we react
back to people being in their place and
sadly that's affected the poorer element
of the country now i don't i'm not going
to dish
eddie redmayne or benedict cumberbatch
for for their schooling that's the what
that happened they they were school and
actually there was the money that was
put into those schools and so the eaton
has a fantastic theater apparently and
so does haro i don't know i haven't seen
them i'm not acquainted with that but at
the same time you go well that's
happened but there is a whole lack
there's a whole slack
part of society which has been ignored
and it's very hard for a young for a
brian cox of today to make that journey
it was much easier in the 60s than it is
now
we have to make sure that it's available
for all not just for a a a
certain section of society brian cox
thank you very much for joining us
and thank you ant
thanks for watching you can listen to
the full interview on our podcast the
economist asks click the link to find
the episode and don't forget to
subscribe